Alright, Charles [LAUGH], let's, let's get back to
the task at hand, and you thought maybe you
had some ideas. So, tell, tell me, how can we define U and pi in terms of Q?
>> Okay. Well, so I guess the first thing
to observe is that U is a value. Right?
>> U are a value. Okay. Yes. U is a value. That's correct.
>> [LAUGH] U returns a number. A
scalar, in particular, where pi returns an action.
>> Yeah, U of s returns a scalar,
that's right, and pi of s returns an action, very good.
>> Right, okay. And, you know, we have the
definition for U up there near the top, and it's
just the reward and then sort of behaving optimally
thereafter, where Q is a reward and then taking a
specific action, and and behaving optimally there after. So,
we can sort of turn Q into U, if we
always pick the best action. And we know the best
action is, it's the one that, you know maximizes the
value that you're going to get from that point on. So, I would say that
U of s could be defined as Max over a of Q, s comma a.
>> Simplicity itself.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Nicely done. I have no idea how we're going to grade
that automatically, because it's hard to type a's under other a's. But,
yeah, that's exactly right, that we have the maximization over all possible
actions of the Q value in that state. Like, that's just great!
>> Mm-hm
>> How about
the policy?
>> So the policy will look exactly the same, the, the,
the policy that you want to follow anyway is the one that...
Maximizes your value going forward except the differences. It's returning an
A and not an actual value, so it should be argmax.
>> Oh, So it's not exactly the same.
>> Right.
>> It's almost exactly the same.
>> Rr… max
>> Right, so this is, it's just so
trivial, so, so Q gives us everything we need.
If only we had a good way of finding Q.
>> Yeah, if only, if only we could find a Q, a Q for you.
>> [LAUGH] and that's going to be the essense of Q LEARNING.
>> Oh, well done.